The Starry Sky has always attracted
people with its unearthly beauty
trillions of other worlds lurk in its
depths which at this moment are quite
inaccessible to us
even there are probes have visited all
sorts of places around the solar system
they're not yet able to Traverse the
interstellar Abyss
to make a step to other stars we need a
new generation space engine powerful and
durable capable of overcoming the Sun's
gravity and remaining fully operational
for all the long years the interstellar
Journey will take
until recently such Technologies
appeared more like science fiction but
new discoveries bring them a little
closer to reality
let's try to figure out what a
hypothetical hyperdriver the future
might be like
it's hardly a secret the distances in
the universe are mind-boggling even with
the best modern engines a journey to the
moon is going to take several weeks and
more than six months to reach Mars by
the most optimal trajectory
if we think about the legendary voyages
after 45 years of traveling through
space they managed to leave only the
inner part of the solar system they are
destined to spend several of the next
Millennia drifting through the scattered
disc and the hypothetical old cloud
the fastest spacecraft at the moment is
the Parker solar probe whose speed in
2025 will reach a record-breaking
194 kilometers per second
however this will happen only due to the
Sun's gravity which will never allow it
to leave the environs of our star and so
the probe is doomed to soon burn up in
its photosphere
apparently chemical jet engines which
are currently so widespread have
exhausted their development potential
and are hardly suitable for Interstellar
travel of course there are various
alternative Concepts such as nuclear
pulse propulsion or cellular sales but
implementation of either of these is
hampered by a number of serious issues
it is highly likely that sooner or later
most of these difficulties will be
overcome another important task crucial
for long-distance travel should be taken
into account
namely the creation of a stable and
Powerful source of energy
all modern spacecraft are relatively
small in size and are equipped with
reliable but low power power sources
for example autonomous research probes
are usually powered by isotope batteries
which inevitably degrade over time if we
revisit the legendary voyages it turns
out that almost all of their systems
have long since been de-energized and
the spacecraft themselves have been
moving by inertia for many years the ISS
and other orbiting space stations
combine solar panels and radioisotope
thermal generators
but most of their power is consumed by
life support systems and the iron drives
serve only to adjust the orbit
in the case of an extended Mound mission
to remote planet or Star however a
spacecraft would need much more power
meanwhile 99 of the way to another star
inevitably passes through Interstellar
space devoid of obvious energy sources
even radiation of the brightest stars is
noticeably weaker here and dissipates in
the vast expanses of space therefore to
travel to other worlds we need an
autonomous powerful and preferably
inexhaustible source of energy to figure
out a potential way of solving this
problem we have to take a closer look at
the University's structure
it is there that a number of amazing
physical processes can be observed which
might prove to contain a key to star's
secrets to do this we have to take a
slight detour
in 2017 a collaborative effort of
scientists from Princeton and Hong Kong
yielded an incredible device that at
first glance violates the fundamental
laws of physics
a microscopic mechanism consisting of
two tooth silicon plates spaced 100
nanometers apart was able to generate a
small amount of energy literally from
nothing
it would seem that such a phenomenon
should grossly violate the law of
conservation of energy one of the
fundamental principles of the universe's
makeup however in fact it is not as
simple as that
the amazing device is based on the
Casimir pelder effect discovered back in
the middle of last century
putting it simply it boils down to this
if two Thin plates are placed in a
vacuum a very small distance apart they
will begin to be mutually attracted the
phenomenon is closely related to the
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle from
which follows the existence of the
so-called zero point vacuum fluctuations
there are pairs of virtual particles
that constantly appear at any point of
the universe by and large out of nowhere
however their lifetime is only 10 to the
power of minus 24 seconds after which
the particles disappear back into
nothingness and the global balance is
restored
at the same time the virtual particles
with any parameters are generated in
open space only those that have strictly
defined wavelengths can be generated
between the plates
consequently more numerous external
particles press on the plates harder
than internal ones just to illustrate
one can imagine that the space between
the plates has a negative pressure it's
as if a little more substance were
pumped out of the vacuum
the resulting mechanical tension can be
transformed into an electric current
which is exactly where the Princeton and
Hong Kong researchers did and although
the current was quite weak it's the
principle itself that matters
because this way our world receives
energy virtually from nothing even a low
power source of inexhaustible energy is
of enormous practical value for example
as an autonomous power supply for
microprocessors and other high Precision
equipment
for example the Voyages equipped with
such a hypothetical battery could still
transmit data from their instruments to
Earth this opens up promising Vistas for
exploring deep space
many interesting physical phenomena
follow from the Casimir Effect one of
which is the so-called sharn horse
defect according to calculations the
speed of light in the space between the
plates should exceed the standard value
of 300 000 kilometers per second because
there are no collisions of photons with
virtual particles although modern
technology does not yet allow this
experiment to be carried out its
mathematical justification leads to
far-reaching conclusions for example the
widely known project of the hypothetical
superluminal engine known as alcubira's
bubble was proven to be potentially
feasible by scientists from Baylor
University Gerald Cleaver and Richard
abusi
they combined the equations of quantum
field Theory and the general theory of
relativity producing a complex but clear
rationale for a bold concept it is worth
mentioning that according to Quantum
field Theory space has not three
dimensions but many more
but this becomes noticeable only at the
level of the microcosm
applying the equations of this Theory to
calculate the Casimir effect the
researchers came to the conclusion that
it is possible to control its properties
with the help of a powerful energy
impact
if we condense the space behind the
hypothetical Starship and make it more
rarified in front then there appears an
area similar to the alcubio bubble which
is capable of moving at superluminal
speeds
the laws of Relativity are not violated
here because it is not the ship itself
that is moving but the space around it
on the other hand from the very
beginning the main problem of creating
such a bubble was considered to be the
incredible amount of energy required
According to some calculations an entire
planet must be converted into radiation
to form a sphere capable of
accommodating a Starship if researchers
manage to scale generators based on the
Casimir effect to the required capacity
we will be able to obtain energy
anywhere in the universe literally from
nothing
of course there are still many problems
to address for a Starship to be fully
operational because outer space is not
the most friendly environment for humans
for example it is permeated with deadly
radiation which not only destroys cells
of living organisms but also causes
negative mutations in their offspring
thick metal Shields or magnetic fields
with certain parameters may be used as
protection against it and both of these
approaches have their advantages and
disadvantages another Potential Threat
could be accidental collisions with
micrometeorites and Cosmic dust at high
velocities even a tiny grain of sand has
incredible kinetic energy and can Pierce
through a metal plate it goes without
saying that on a long Interstellar
flight repair options are extremely
limited and a hole in the hull may prove
to be fatal
in addition a long Expedition without
support from Earth requires creating a
closed biosphere within the starship
scientists from different countries are
currently working on this for example
various plants have been grown on board
the ISS for quite a number of years both
for scientific purposes and for
consumption in addition to that
Engineers are developing systems for
recycling waste including biological
waste products however a fully fledged
orbital ecosystem is still a long way
off
of course problems that Space Explorers
May encounter are not limited to these
after all we've only taken our first
steps beyond our planet and many nuances
of the universe remain hidden from us
obviously the effects of such exotic
fields on the human organism are still
understudied and in the future
scientists are bound to encounter new
challenges the solutions to which will
lead to further discoveries who knows
maybe one of them will make us see the
universe in a new light
foreign
[Music]
[Music]